[Music]
psychedelic drugs
are commonly reported to trigger
life-altering mind-expanding inward
journeys
but since being scheduled dangerous and
illegal any therapeutic benefits
have gone largely
unrecognized
mental health treatment hasn't changed
in generations
limited primarily to psychotherapy and a
broad drug class called
ssris or selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors
so there's been no new drug in
psychiatry essentially
since ssris back in the 1980s
these drugs have varying results often
with side effects
and can be seriously habit-forming once
you get on one ssri
they've got you for life pretty much but
this model could soon be disrupted by
the acceptance of psychedelics by the
medical psychiatric and pharmacological
communities
this is now coming at the forefront
after spending
60 years in hiding and these tools
actually have remarkable healing
potential and have had for
thousands of years lsd
psilocybin dmt mdma
and other consciousness altering
compounds once labeled dangerous in
illegal drugs
are coming into the political spotlight
a recent ballot measure in oregon
authorized the legal use of psilocybin
by licensed providers clinical trials
are pressing forward in what could
forever change the way we understand
and treat both the mind and the body
investors are flocking to stake their
claim in this new frontier
of magic molecules what is really
driving us here
is the fact that the efficacy rates here
cannot be ignored they're profound
and money will follow efficacy
but these investors aren't just hedging
their bets they're true believers
intent on flooding psychedelic startups
with the capital they need
to invoke a revolution of the mind
[Music]
the word psychedelic is derived from the
ancient greek word psyche meaning soul
and elune meaning to reveal it
translates to mind manifesting
and the first real documented use of
psychedelics can actually be traced back
to that same era
from 1600 bc to 396 a.d
in the greek culture the foundations of
western culture
they had the longest running mystery
ceremonies ever
and they were involved with the
psychedelic drug
potion called kikion which we now
through modern scholarship have
identified as being similar to lsd
rick doblin is the founder of the
multi-disciplinary association
for psychedelic studies or maps our top
priority project
is mdma assisted psychotherapy for
post-traumatic stress disorder
and we're in phase three studies right
now so rick how long have you been
involved in this
i started maps in 86. in the upcoming
scene
we will watch a young man who was having
a difficult experience
while under the influence of the
psychedelic drug i really got
involved in trying to devote my life to
psychedelics and becoming a psychedelic
therapist in 1972.
so i imagine things have changed quite a
bit since then oh my god
everything has changed america's public
enemy number one
is drug abuse when i began it was
the depth of the backlash in 1970 the
controlled substances
act was passed in the united states
psychedelics were criminalized
the research was squashed extensive
experimentation has failed to establish
a medical use for lsd
after nixon mainstream acceptance of
psychedelics was impossible
and these compounds went underground
where it stayed for over a half century
associated with counterculture and
degeneracy
taking lsd is much the same as playing
russian roulette what are you doing out
here
i'm floating i'm floating up to the
stars you can't
but guys like rick doblin continued
their research on the fringes
and so what's changed now is the public
attitudes have changed
the regulatory agencies are open to
research we just completed a 30 million
dollar capstone campaign
for our mdma ptsd phase 3 studies and
for commercialization
we're in a major psychedelic renaissance
right now
and now we have these new tools for
neuroscience to really understand
what these drugs do in the brain but
that is not an easy question to answer
there are a lot of drugs out there that
we don't know how they work you only
have to show
that a drug is safe and that it's
effective you don't
have to know how a drug works to get it
approved
i mean asking how psychedelics work
seems almost as challenging as asking
what is the meaning of life i think i
think
if we have the answer to one we'll have
the answer to the other dr charles
nichols is professor of pharmacology
at louisiana state university health
sciences center
i primarily study serotonin
neuropharmacology
a focus on psychedelic drugs so tell me
a little bit about what we know
is happening to the brain on say lsd or
psilocybin what the psychedelics do
is they target a selective
subset of serotonin receptors
the one that produces the psychedelic
effects is called the serotonin
2a receptor a lot of positive effects
are associated with
with activation of that receptor okay so
how about a less
scientific explanation unscientifically
what psychedelics do in the brain
you're having several brain areas that
are talking to one another that don't
normally talk to one another and you've
established
new connections new pathways there's one
theory that posits
that when that trip starts to wear off
the network will reset more into a
normal connectivity state than
say if somebody was depressed so what
kind of tests in the lab do you perform
to devise these theories
we've developed two rat-based models
where we can essentially create a
depressed rat
give it a single dose of psilocybin and
the rats
that were given psilocybin are now
acting like normal rats
they're not depressed i'm curious how do
you know a rat is depressed
oh it just kind of hangs out in its
corner doesn't like to do much
but these laboratory observations don't
speculate on what happens during the
actual
trip and this is where the therapy
really comes in
[Music]
it's not a question of whether the
science permits it
but it's how we use these tools these
are powerful tools but we still haven't
quite figured out or at least we're
still working on the best way to use
them
shlomi raz is ceo and founder of ellucis
he along with other up-and-coming
startups are designing the methodology
to safely and effectively practice
psychedelic medicine
[Music]
much of their inspiration comes from
ancient shamanic practices such as
ayahuasca ceremonies in south america
which have become increasingly popular
among people seeking alternative forms
of healing after traditional treatments
have failed them
so shlomi what's the most important
thing we can learn from these
shamanistic practices
as you design modern therapeutic
applications
that this clinical rollout be done in a
way that
treats the therapeutic potential and
power of these drugs with respect and i
think that would be the biggest mistake
is that if
in a rush to commercialization that
there is a loss
of respect associated with development
maybe you can walk me through your
vision
of a psychedelic therapy session i think
number one this is not the job of a
psychiatrist
number two we're not sure that you even
want a psychotherapist in the room
instead the person that we think should
be in the room
is an attendant someone where you feel
safe in their presence
are they certified you know medical
professionals not necessarily
but they bring an instant rapport and an
instant comfort and they're
what they're comfortable with is
emotionally intense situations
with this process the patients heal
themselves
and the need for antidepressants or
other long-term prescription drugs
could fade away but the potential for
these compounds go
far beyond mental health treatment
multiple studies have found that regular
minute doses of lsd
and similar compounds have enormous
anti-inflammatory effects
potentially offering alternative
treatments to everything from asthma
to migraine headaches you know we have
some very interesting clues
that there's much more therapeutic
potential just beneath the surface
all of this is not only revolutionary
but potentially disruptive
to the estimated 16 billion dollar
antidepressant drug market
when you take a look at some of these
compounds and molecules there are 70 75
80 percent efficacy rates so that is
that's
profound and that will disrupt big
pharma
saad shah leads a venture fund called
noetic and he is what you would call
a true believer i mean it's definitely
very personal it's personal
first and foremost because i personally
have you know
drunk the brew
i had an experience with plant medicine
and it was profound in many levels
i saw the distinct impact that it had
on folks that were suffering from cancer
individuals that were suffering from
very serious treatment resistant
depression
major depressive disorders ptsd anxiety
i knew then and there that there was
something here that was
incredibly profound okay so there's
certainly a motivation to keep people on
drugs and these compounds often do the
opposite
which essentially means there's less
money to be made
how is big pharma not trying to squash
this movement
if you're finding a market and a product
is working
and clearly you've got underlying
companies are going to profit as a
result of it
this is going to be of interest to big
partners i think that they will get more
and more more involved
and i think it's important for them to
get involved because at the end of the
day
we need this medicine to go out there to
the globe
and you need a distribution platform big
pharma has that distribution platform
they're the ones that can help get it
out there but that optimism might be
putting a little too much faith in a
profit-based apparatus that has enabled
severe drug dependencies like the opioid
crisis in america
for these compounds to truly scale it's
not only our minds
but our entire society that might need a
rewiring
there needs to definitely be a
redefining
of profit of capitalism profit needs to
first be measured in human capital
right healing those who have suffered if
we do that right
our investment in the companies will
succeed
you